what's up taste buddies i am hitting the
road to do stand-up comedy finally i
haven't been out in a while all tickets
available at
savilecanocomedy.com right now i will be
in
uh fort lauderdale to dania uh improv uh
november 12th through the 14th i will be
in the west palm beach improv uh
december 4th and 5th i will be
uh at in boston in medford at the cheval
year i don't know if i'm saying that
right theater december 10th boston come
out you always come out big and then i'm
really excited about this one the
borgata in atlantic city new jersey i
performed there like so many times with
the guys never solo first one that's
gonna be a lot of fun uh where else we
going with this the week between
christmas and new year's eve december 26
dallas december 27 san antonio december
28th sugarland december 29th st louis
missouri december 30th column columbus
ohio and new year's eve in cincinnati
ohio all co-headlining with chrissy d
all tickets savile kennel comedy.com
right now
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to the mic i'm
talking hey
buddies it's monday
mondays are for the buds welcome to
t-a-s-t-e
buds happy all saints day happy all
saints day november 1 everybody's
recovering everyone's hung over from
last night yeah all hallows eve what'd
you do last night
we can't even talk about it we can't
even we're pre-recording so the fate of
the halloween parade that we discussed
at length
on this show is unknown until next week
right
no no until even further down yeah
no no
no it's next week
yeah oh one week from today okay okay
one week behind so then they'll know
okay we have to do it because we have to
edit the episode and put it up blah blah
blah so we'll know yeah then we'll know
okay and by the way i need to say this
in homie p's uh defense
uh i saw comments today about the the
ads
people were like pimp just leaves the
mistakes in he doesn't care it's
hilarious so then i text pimp in a panic
right i text pip in a panic and i go hey
dude i'm seeing this account like what
is this and he goes no dude i left in
the bit where you couldn't pronounce the
word microbial yeah and i go oh that's
funny and then i said sorry pimp i i
panicked a little bit and uh you know
what else a couple weeks back the people
you always say i'm good i always i
wanted to make sure you feel good the
fans are rats i want to make sure
i want to make sure you feel good that i
feel good that you feel good that i feel
good of course i know you're just double
checking you know what i mean
yeah i mean if you see that message you
should ask him and let him explain
uh
the people that will like you're right
sal always says you should be harder on
him and i say no he's
no i mean i i agree like naturally i
would see that comment and want to
investigate it yeah uh
the people who were complaining about
english muffin versus pop tart what are
you doing what are you doing who was
just complaining i should have went
against a toaster strudel no
because those two things are way too
similar sometimes we like to put things
that are purposefully different but
check the same box that is a breakfast
treat both of them are
widely known as a breakfast
thing predominantly that you put in a
toaster when you wake up in the morning
one is sweet one is savory right
one is sugary one is more traditional
but they still are in the same bucket i
don't want to we don't always want to
put something up against something that
is kind of exactly the same thing with a
different name brand i'm going to clear
the air sometimes i'm going to clear the
air yeah
i want to start doing pizza versus we're
going to
like we'll do whatever we want correct
come here lean in come here
lean in closer lean in closer
i love when people say we think this
would be a fun battle
we love all of that we invite you guys
to participate in things i'm not too
thrilled with the people
that are
talking down to us
about our own show as if they created it
exec producers uh and aren't getting it
for free
right
that's what i think squeaky wheels yeah
if you like it give it a listen a like
and subscribe share it it's a big i see
us all that jazz if you don't like it
don't it's a big idea today that we're
gonna do um uh it's it's we
you know what it is already but it's
it's young halloween versus old
halloween and you know what i just
realized we never chose our sides
oh in my head i was about to just
announce what my side was so in my head
bounce it i i like the challenge of it
because i could take either side i i i
could do there's pros and cons to both
but in my forgot we didn't in my head i
was about to go and i have this go ahead
what do you have halloween as a what do
you think i'm gonna say
i think you're
i think you're gonna say as a kid
but then i think you're gonna say as an
adult just to screw me
why would that be screwing you you'll
pick things sometimes and i think it's
fishy
so
wait you just
said pick whatever one you want i know
but under that pretense i it would be
unable for me to screw you you just gave
me the i know i'm joe i'm i know you're
joking but i'm just good
sometimes i think you picked something i
go that's not his favorite he just said
that's why i can't use it really yeah oh
i don't know let's tell let me know
which ones i'll confirm with tonight i
don't think i did that uh
i don't think he did either again just a
joke please just having a little pod fun
over here
what are you picking i was going to say
halloween as a kid so that goes against
what you just said great because you
said it was screwed i wanted adults all
right so there you go
why wouldn't you say that here we go
ready yes
i think this one might get heated
maybe maybe
but it doesn't matter if i can see it
because
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you
here we go
b-a-t-t-l-e buzz
sorry i was still reeling from the other
chance you closed your eyes a little bit
through that because it does get awkward
it's a real i like yeah it's weird it's
weird
it's weird yeah it's weird yeah but but
you've got to mean it yeah you got to
mean it yeah that's true so let's never
get butterflies during that
during that part
like it was like the fourth time we've
ever swept
or like nervous butterflies uh either
way it could be yeah
kind of like yeah like when you start
holding hands for the first time yeah i
know what you mean
no but it is a weird feeling
i uh it is weird i love that you picked
as a kid
and i love that i picked as an adult how
do you want to do this would you like to
launch right now would you like to start
going want me to go
well i'm happy to tell you that
halloween as an adult is better because
it is all the amenities of halloween as
a kid
every single thing you can do as a kid
on halloween you do as an adult except
you also add booze
drugs and sex
i don't see where the loss is on this
[Laughter]
i'm sorry is sex guaranteed on halloween
i think
how
you know it's you got a good shot of
getting laid at a halloween party yeah
people are out sniffing around yeah you
know much more so than you would at a
christmas party i would say sure sure
i'll attach my wagon to the exact
opposite reason for why i think kids is
better
right i mean those things are booze
drugs and sex you can have any time it's
not the same experience because you're
removed and intangible you're moved to
the magic
oh i think there's magic what i still
think there's magic no no but as a kid
the innocence of halloween yes the the
the the gravity of what halloween is the
anticipation of becoming a character and
having the you have you also have the uh
the autonomy your parents let you you
choose something you want to become it's
usually a hero of yours or something
that you really love you get to take on
another character you feel that in your
bones more as a kid than you do as an
adult as well as the fear
the movies that come with it the walking
in the streets the the going to a house
that has a graveyard there or someone
that jumps out or something that lights
up and scares you uh the communal thing
with your friends
it was monumental when halloween
approached okay candy which is the the
cornerstone of the holiday
means so much more it's actual currency
as a child
as an adult we are probably right
we don't even don't care for the candy
we don't care you know when you boil
halloween down to what it is most
traditionally it is getting on a costume
and going
roaming
from home to home being able to knock on
doors and ring bells
of people
it's it's a social faux pas it is it is
partially illegal in a way for the other
364 days and on this day no matter which
home it is whether they answer the door
or not you are well within your rights
and they know it to walk on their
property ring their bell you soak it in
you soak in if they decorate it if they
didn't is anyone home i don't know well
there's a light on the back are they
trying to hide for us are they out with
their kids ring it how long do we wait
you ever ring it then you wait and you
wait and you wait and someone goes it's
the dead the house is dead the heights
are off and you're like i don't know you
ring it one more time you go to walk
away take three steps and then they come
to the door and then all of a sudden
it's like a regular sized candy what
that feels like winning the lottery all
these little things all these feelings
that we carry through with us to adult
that we have nostalgia for halloween are
active and vibrant in a child during
halloween all the senses are awoken you
believe in halloween okay not to mention
coming home
and rationing out the candy like you're
putting in your savings trading with
friends then you got a candy drawer for
like a month to come
i mean you could even have a halloween
party as a child too i went to halloween
parties my birthday's november early
november a lot of people mess it up so i
like to keep it a secret uh but i used
to have sometimes halloween parties
birthday parties or go to halloween
parties so just as because you're an
adult you can go out partying doesn't
mean you can't have the kid party
version of that exact same thing i think
okay so i think what you're really
locking into
about halloween as a kid is is really
autonomy it's all that's really what it
is it's the night your parents let you
leave the house with your friends for
the first time
uh without a chaperone you're allowed
but even going but but even but but take
it out of that that's when you're way
too young it really gets to be fun when
you're about 10 and your parents say you
guys can actually go out by yourselves
and you go out into the streets and it's
dark out and it's a school night yet
you're still allowed out to a later time
you you get dressed up
you do all this
wild stuff
that really brings the holiday to life
for you as a child but really what that
all is based in is autonomy and when
you're an adult you have the ultimate
autonomy and you do all of these things
exactly according to
your own rule book which is what i love
you still get dressed up uh but the
costumes can even be crazier you go and
buy the exact candy you want instead of
taking the dice roll on the gambler
it's a hell of a lot of fun no no i
bought you one
bag you don't know what you're getting i
could be getting a nickel pushed into an
animal
five pennies together so i could be
getting a king-size snickers i'll tell
you what fun it could still be i had a
halloween get-together last year with a
few of us i had you guys over right i
went to a candy store in my neighborhood
and i bought a grab bag of halloween
candy i didn't know what was in it and i
dumped it into a bowl and i was excited
to have that in my house it was fun it
was fun i had it for months afterwards
like you said uh you
you have a you you can you can still go
out for look if you really want to you
can find a way to trick or treat as an
adult you can find a kid in your family
that needs a chaperone or something like
that and go out there and do it too but
there's something you're not harping on
you said sex booze partying and and
drugs
but uh
what about the uh and i shouldn't even
be saying this but what about the adult
halloween experience of bringing their
child and
reliving it vicaracy through the child
well you can do so so the other angle of
the adult halloween is that you bring
the kids and i will tell you though if
you're gonna harp on that
the reason it's so special is because
you're reliving the magic you felt
watching your kids do it so it's tied
back to kid halloween
i think that's a like you said that's a
venn diagram i think i think that's true
and i don't think that that's a real
version i think it's a valid argument to
add but i don't think
what
to me it's the most beautiful part of
your side of the argument no it's stupid
it's stupid you tried to give them
something you tried no it's stupid
well then let me just tell you because
it's living by character
is like uh for me then it's like
halloween night is like saint patty's
halloween night is like
how are you how dare you
how dare you new year's eve it's amateur
hour [ __ ]
it's fun how dare you you said not but
two weeks or one week ago on this very
show that the halloween party parade is
your favorite thing to happen in new
york city and that you love partaking on
it and i said it's like bourbon street
times 11 and you said no that's wrong
it's an amazing experience right
so how can you say halloween is amateur
hour then well i'm not talking about the
parade i'm talking about the sex booze
and that's what the parade is no it's
not it's an adult parade where you said
everybody gets drunk and throws candy
out to adults and packed bars well you
you you're allowed to drink you're not
allowed but people are drinking in
public so that's fun but you you're
watching adults
music costumes floats you're seeing like
art installations you're throwing candy
to people well they scream for you in
cheer of the holidays
it's awesome
it is awesome
for you to call that amateur you know
you're full of [ __ ] on that one i don't
think your parade is amateur hour the
parade i don't think is amateur that is
the epitome of adult halloween that
parade it's yeah so argue that so much
to the point that i'm hesitant about
whether or not i want to go to it
because it takes the thing i love about
halloween and amps it up so much that
i'm like i don't know if i can handle
this man it's too much to bomb you've
never been there right huh you've never
been to i've been there several times oh
okay so i don't know what you mean did
you have a march in the parade no i
never marched okay i'm i'm talking about
us marching i understand okay it's
actually different
it's different if i suck it sorry
side sidewalk with 800 drunk people
screaming and yelling and pissing and
fighting and spilling out of a bar i'm
just talking about how i also read
people that say new year's eve is
amateur hour are people that think new
year's eve is times square ball drop
that is amateur hour okay but now you're
gonna go to any bar new year
any bar you're right on that one too
but any
decently put together new year's eve
event in a house of house permit it's
awesome you get all your closest friends
together [ __ ] pros and cons yeah but
i mean it's like so like my point is
this with with halloween is it's full
autonomy you can when you're an adult
you do it exactly how you want how
exactly like it's almost like saying
like look there's a magic to christmas
and i'm still swept away by christmas
every year okay there's a magic to
christmas when you're a kid that magic
is still there when you're an adult and
it's even better when you're an adult
because not only are you receiving i
think we're chasing christmas our whole
lives after that i don't i disagree
chasing a feeling and even a different
feeling as a kid is so good that the
feeling we chase only has to be a
fraction you know and also and also the
feeling as a kid can be so bad because
you're at the mercy of what other people
are willing to allow you to do or gift
you and a lot of the times you get burnt
okay your mom you tell your mom you i
want this thing she gets it mixed up
with that thing when i think back
whatever it is granted that we're
pivoting to christmas in relation but
i'm just saying but let me finish let me
know when you're gonna let me pick let
me finish my let me finish my halloween
argument my point is when you get older
christmas to me becomes a much more
special thing because you do it on your
own terms you have the you have the full
adult autonomy to control in a way that
you would like to and i think that makes
it even more magical because you're able
to bring joy to other people it's not
just about you being on the receiving
end me me me i get i get i get i get
which is what halloween is a kid is it's
me me me give me give me give me give me
give me it's not you spreading any of
that joy to anybody it's only you
receiving that joy when you're an adult
you can put on a halloween thing that
brings up all the reminiscing the
reminiscence and the nostalgia and the
feelings that you got when you're a kid
by having an awesome spread of candy by
putting these cobwebs up in the smoke
machines in the house by having booze
and and or
doing an adult style with booze or
whatever and suddenly i'm right back
there man
i'm right back there look we're talking
pros and cons right i'm not saying i
love halloween even as an adult but if i
had to choose between the two i choose
kid and and honestly christmas is the
tougher one for me because i love it so
much but think about when you thought he
was real that's only like a window of
like x amount of years when did you
think what did you think was real on
halloween did you think goblins were
real
like did you think ghosts were gonna
come out but i bought i never thought
that no but i just bought into
everything so much more it was about the
spirit neighborhood about the candy
about the how people decorated their
house
better costume was that's the spirit on
christmas the spirit is giving and love
and your friends convoluting it with
christmas right now i'm saying though
there's a difference between believing
that a santa claus is real and getting
into the spirit of a holiday there's
nothing to believe in on halloween
you're swept away by the spirit and that
spirit is even stronger in my opinion
when you're an adult
i i don't believe so i believe that what
you celebrate on halloween changes and i
don't discount how good a halloween can
be and how fulfilling it can be for an
adult for all the reasons you mentioned
but when you're talking about
the music you've noticed that i'm doing
this notice it you're taunting me with
it yeah yeah so i noticed so as intended
the fourth time yeah you wanted to do it
yeah one as it's on me four times you
wanted me to notice and i noticed and
you go you noticed i said i mean but i
can't believe you're not saying anything
well i'm just trying to keep going here
and i did it quietly but now if you want
to make a whole segment out of it i i do
think what what sal is trying to say is
once you have your adult identity you
can't really get lost in the magic of
halloween i disagree with that i'm a
horror movie
i'm a horror movie
nerd okay i have a horror movie podcast
i've written horror movies i can't i
collect horror movies i read her fiction
as much as i can you're not a horror
movie nerd you're a nerd who likes
horror movies
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right movie nerd would
i should say i'm a horror nerd i read
horror comic books i play horror video
games i love i collect horror action i
love horror stuff yes i know that about
you i am this so so you want to talk
spirit for halloween this year for our
halloween for the month of october
i picked out because i have a backlog of
horror movies i haven't watched yet that
i bought that i still haven't gotten to
i picked out a i picked out like 25 of
those movies and got them set and i was
like i'm watching one of these every
single night in october i am so excited
about halloween okay so i'm gonna show
you something so this is doing you a
better service in my opinion than just
talking about like it's a hookup night
you get you're going no the parties are
great believe me i know the parties i
used to throw them i threw them every
year i just started with the hookup
stuff that's a bonus i understand but i
was soft-serving you the tie-in to the
nostalgia as the adult living
vicariously to the child but you just
threw that away i don't because i think
there's a better i think there's a true
and an adult
a truly wondrous adult experience to
have with halloween that has nothing to
do with kids and trick-or-treating and
taking the kid out to watch the kid have
fun the way you did and what that's a
whole different thing okay that's the
same reason why parents get excited the
for the first thanksgiving or or to to
put the candy out at easter and hide the
eggs or all that stuff that's different
that's not what i'm talking about i
think just like christmas halloween is
one of the only holidays where you can
still no matter what age get just as
swept up in the magic as you wanted to
let's take i would
i would say that that let's say
let's say you're the adult that has the
haunted house that the kids come to
gangbusters right i'll say that's
feasible for certain adults i think the
overall arcing story about adulthood
though is that it's like a little more
like on the whole people are just more
blase about it i'm not talking about the
the halloween
oh did we get a zuma i hope that was
like that was like everywhere we see an
uh an airplane where he's like i have a
drinking problem
[Laughter]
um no i think that i think that you're
right i think that for the people who
who are children at heart who who love
to make the haunted house on the block
who love to i'm going to watch a horror
movie every night those people still
exist and that is a great argument
there's merit there but i think as as a
whole adults tend to sour and get a
little lackluster on the holidays and
even if they do participate sometimes
you get like that guy are we going i
don't know if we're going to go what are
you going to be you know what i got a
referee i got a footlocker shirt in mind
i think i'll just go as a referee it's i
think
i think proof positive that your point
on that is wrong
is the halloween parade that you love so
much
that doesn't happen for any other
holiday you have parades but the parades
are guys with their
kid on their shoulders and and you're
looking at balloons and santa waves and
all that [ __ ] and it's it's daytime
whatever halloween is the one holiday
where at night
the thing happens at night and it's all
grown-ups getting [ __ ]
i i will tell you this i love halloween
as a kid as an adult i love it i
all right keeps it's helping you keep
your hair it's helping you prevent
further hair loss and maintain what it
is you have two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35 i never knew it was that
early in life i got a little thing going
on back here i know i've had it
oh really
i mock you behind your back frequently
well that's not what you do to anyone
who's balding or a friend no no not
that's why i do it to you
[Laughter]
more than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness i
didn't even know there were 50 million
men in the u.s
kidding there are only two fda approved
medications guess what that can prevent
hair loss keeps has both of them in it
keeps offers both this is a that now
you're gonna get a convenient virtual
doctor consultation and medication
delivered straight to your door every
three months so you don't have to leave
your home that's huge low cost
treatments start just at ten dollars per
month which is amazing uh and uh
discrete packaging
proven results what more could you ask
it's coming to your house doctor right
there on your computer screen discreet
packaging proven results affordable
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
fast there's no doubt that i mean just
from these stats alone a lot of our
listeners probably you know this they
could use this so so just try it why not
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash taste buds receive your first
month of treatment completely for free
that's k-e-p-s dot com slash taste buds
to get your first month free one more
time for the people in the back
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash taste buds
you know why i like to peloton and we're
gonna talk about pelton for a second
can i guess why you like it sure can i
guess yeah let's make this into a whole
thing it's not just
state-of-the-art cardio exercise okay
it's also strength training
that is
one of the reasons i love it
for me everything about exercising is a
routine okay if i don't have a routine i
don't stick to it if i know what i gotta
do when i gotta do it i stick to it
having the bike in my house makes it's
so convenient for me to have a chance to
because when i get busy if i can just
finish my points
when i get busy yeah the first thing
that i cut out is okay i can sacrifice
the exercise so as long as i know that
it's i at 10 o'clock i go upstairs i do
my 25 minutes i do my 30 minutes by the
way you think 20 minutes 30 minutes is
not that long i am you can get a workout
like where you literally feel like
you're going to collapse off that's
great and i'll tell you this your
exercise is a routine
and i've seen your routine it's exercise
stand up comedy
yeah i i love what peloton's doing it's
we're all on the go these days it seems
it's hard to get motivated they're
offering you inspiring instructors that
are allowing for extra encouragement and
structured workouts uh and who are fun
and funny to watch the curated music
helps okay you truly feel like you're
when you're in the class and you're
watching the guy and he's like oh the
gal the instructor whoever it is you've
you can look at your rankings you feel
like you're in there you feel the energy
of the room it's different than throwing
in your headphones and just listening to
the music right that's what it really is
and i like that you still can pick
something that that suits your mood for
that day one subscription for the whole
family by the way all access membership
it's like a family plan for no
additional cost experience motivation
like never before with the peloton bike
go to onepelton.com to learn more that's
one o and e peloton p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
we spoke about this i used to throw a
party every year at where i worked and i
also would throw a halloween and a
parade excursion every year the last
five or six years i haven't done a damn
thing halloween has snuck up on me i've
been working i've been a little too busy
i barely i make sure i get out to take
my nieces uh trick-or-treating but like
other than that i haven't picked a
costume i haven't gone to a party and i
love halloween but it just sneaks up on
you and you almost sometimes it just
takes a back seat and you're not as
enthused and i think that most adults
fall into that campus so yes i am
speaking in general terms there's always
outliers but every kid
feels the same every weight of halloween
i think about i agree i agree when you
when when uh september rolled around
back to school you're closing october
hits once october first hits and cvs and
all the stores make those changes and
people start putting on those
decorations you
start thinking about what your costume
is going to be the way you start
thinking of like
you know what your wedding day is you
you're like what what am i going to do
this show
you're going to be different than next
year how am i going to impress everybody
am i going to win the contest at school
are they going to know who i am i'm
going to walk up to my friends am i
going to scare them are they going to
know who i am oh my god and seeing like
costumes they just mean so much and
candy it just means i don't think much i
don't think i i think your most adult's
argument is very flawed that's the part
i disagree with i think that's like
saying most kids aren't i knew kids that
weren't allowed to go trick-or-treating
they weren't allowed to celebrate it i
went to catholic school i knew kids that
weren't allowed because their parents
thought it was a devil's holiday
uh
i think google google has halloween
and that the definition like what is it
i think again i'm just gonna feed back
on it's putting on a costume going
door-to-door and getting freaking i
understand this i understand this but i
say i'm saying you saying i think most
adults fall out with halloween i think
that would be like saying most kids
aren't allowed to even go out
trick-or-treat i think it's just
completely inaccurate i think most
adults are probably more involved in
halloween for the reasons that you're
stating they have kids and they get into
it and they love it i think the adults
that don't have kids are going out and
seeing it as a nightcap most mostly
everybody i know
who is
uh married but doesn't have children
don't have children when halloween it is
it is just like new year's eve in the
sense of okay we are like doing
something big yeah it never goes with it
never goes with we sat home i had to
twist your arm to hang out with me on
this halloween twist your arm no you
didn't we went back and forth in text 20
times in the group chat babe and you
were like i'm not gonna are fine you
finally babe that was not me i was the
one leading the group when i said i want
to do the apartment crawl for halloween
where every house is a different drink
and a different candy that was my whole
thing i get into this i'm telling you
that
you're thinking of jay
who when we showed it to his apartment
his drink was orange soda that he dumped
vodka into and he had no costume on
oh yeah and then also made us watch the
tail end of ufc before we were allowed
to go and do halloween things let me let
me let me bring in another contender in
this argument let's go to
uh halloween
13 14 15
okay still a kid when it becomes now
you know
you could also go trick-or-treating but
then you're also going bombing
yeah
for three or four and i don't know if
it's a regional thing but if you don't
know what this is you would get usually
what it is is eggs and shaving cream
those are the two big hallmarks of it
and
you would go with your friends and you
all go to the store and get shaving
cream you put a pin in it and so the
shaving cream would shoot out and then
you just get eggs to literally throw
each other or
put eggs in a sock
or with with baby powder and things like
that and then you take the sock and whip
people and and break the eggs over them
now
that was a little more like you had to
know the person or be ready to get into
a fight but like it wasn't about like
vandalism either like they they didn't
like it because errant eggs would hit
cars and yolk is not good for paint but
when i was younger until they banned all
this there was a
growing up you waited too you'd see the
older kids you would be
trick-or-treating and the older kids
like the 15-year-old kids right
i'm listening to you okay because it
feels like you're not no i'm listening
to you i'm just looking at the thing
okay pimp pull up because it reminded me
of something we wanted to touch you'd be
like you know oh greatest costume too by
the way okay
you'd be seven
nine ten and you'd be trick-or-treating
and all the kids in any groups whether
you knew them or not they knew you had a
costume on you were about that halloween
life but not this halloween life and
they would let you go but you'd see the
13 year olds 16 year olds they'd walk by
and they their clothes their hair would
be just covered in white shaving cream
egg all over them and they'd be like two
three ten kids walking and then they'd
see the kids from the other neighborhood
and then it was on it was in the middle
of street it was like it was like like
like like bravery
people are just just
boom there's explosions of the power
eggs are coming in people are just
getting slapped in the face with we
didn't shoot it it was a hoot our
parents let us do it and then they
started banning them
that would ban them and stores that you
they'd still let you do it and some
stores would be like uh we're not
selling you eggs or shaving cream and
some people would like get out of here
get out we were when we were when we
were that age we did two things we
number one started to do participate in
like truly scary haunted houses
like one like like meaning we would be
in them
uh like what do you mean
we work at the local haunted house yeah
you did that yeah oh wow that's amazing
it might be such a rush to be able to
scare people legally like that it like
one it was so exciting and it was so
much it was so exciting it was so hard
to not giggle your [ __ ] ass off and
how bad you were about to scare the [ __ ]
out of somebody that was really hard oh
i want to do that should we do that i'm
going to do that one night you want to
do that i could hook that up for us i
know a couple of people that have
haunted houses
for all the years i'll say we could just
put on a mess and go in there and be the
ones
i don't go to haunted houses okay so i
do i like i like haunted house so i went
twice so i got a couple i have to close
my eyes and run and just swing i got a
three-fold thing here so that we started
doing that the other thing we started
doing was we had underage dance clubs
like where they'd have underage night
and we would start they would not yeah
not under it it was like it was like
kids under 18.
and then like and so they would do like
halloween things sometimes and then all
the kids would go and then you really
felt like you were the [ __ ] because
you're going to like a nightclub i got
dropped off there on stage so stapleton
and then last week
i had diet cokes all night lastly i
started going to
real haunted houses right so like
halloween horror nights which i went to
when i was in my 30s but um at my late
my mid to late teens is when i start to
actually go to these things because they
have they have haunted houses where it's
like you have to sign a thing that says
like if you die like you like it's not a
gimmick it's like no dude this is
intense it's scary but halloween horror
nights at universal studios i took my
mom there me my buddy scott my mom and
my dad went
we had a blast and they these things
were scary as [ __ ]
like long dark hallways that you just
had to walk down and you knew [ __ ] was
going to jump out i love all that it was
so you could do that
in a way but these these are these are
intentional i'm talking about like the
exorcist like she jumped off the bench
did you see them terrifying see the
crazy ones now would you go in the 100
alone and 100 pitch black some of them
some of them are 100 alone pitch black
and naked that i won't do
yeah but there's ones where you go alone
in every room it's a very intense
experience they tie you up they stuff
something in your mouth they put a gun
to your head i swear to god dude there's
crazy ones it's not a haunted house
that's just a horrid experience yeah
yeah the haunted house actor stabbed an
11 year old boy's foot while trying to
scare him i see that
that's terrible i mean he shouldn't have
an actual blade but yeah let me just let
me just seven because this thing was
called seven floors of hell
oh my god that's because he stabs him
upon entry then he has to walk the seven
foot
the uh but then also too
we this reminded me because the kid got
hurt i hope he's okay
it's just what we we we teased we teased
last week that the the scares of um the
big
what did what did you call it the hype
scare of the razor blades and the candy
and all that oh the fear-mongering yeah
yeah that was all that that was a
communal
this is gonna sound weird
but
as a child everything like your world
the universe is what your neighborhood
is and your universe is what your
parents tell you and when you
when everyone is on the same page and
you have the shared universe
as scary or as weird as it could have
been to hear like there's needles in the
candy there's razors in the apples
there's a van going around
right i think about that fondly in a way
because it never came to fruition it was
it was we always just heard that but all
the kids were on hyper alert
you know to like i don't know what dude
there was an air
of anything could happen right and i
would say that that's yet another bonus
of being an adult at halloween is you're
not taking
[ __ ] from a stranger's house you know
what you're getting you're controlling
your intake
but now dude ringing someone's bell's
the best thing in the world how hot is
that though think about that think about
how odd that is think about how odd it
is i love that for a second
i think that's the best thing about how
odd that is in this society we live in
yeah this this children are the future
protected at all costs nobody can take
any chances yeah society we live in
halloween is the only time where the
roles are completely reversed the adults
are curating everything for themselves
whatever and the kids they go just walk
up to the doors and whatever you get is
whatever you get right that's nuts i
know and that's why i love it so my mom
for two years broke every piece of candy
apart before i was allowed to eat it to
make sure there were no pins or my mom
did too and by the way was that real or
was it an old wife i think it was more
tail
tail or not at all what's that called
one person but then it was like that it
was like the shoe bomber so anyway so
now um
but but i'll say this too oh let's do
let's
i have a fun story we should go to the
phones in a minute but let's do let's do
best costume because pimp wanted to know
i don't i i i have to i know both of
mine
yeah my best visually and i will try to
find pictures of these
my best visually was beetlejuice i
bought a beetlejuice mask the way with
the year beetlejuice came out and it was
really itchy and it hurt my face and i
was like dad like i'm sorry like i i
wanted to be just i can't wear this mask
like it's horrible i can't it hurts
so my dad my dad's very creative and
he's very handy and uh he took the mask
and he cut the face out so i just had
the beetlejuice hair and ears and
everything makeup and then he did the
makeup and made it blend in
with the mask and i had the trench coat
i had cobwebs all over me it was it was
an awesome i'd love to see a photo i'm
gonna try to find a photo but my best
one i have to say
uh i was freddy krueger
i was so young you couldn't buy the
freddy krueger glove yet like that
wasn't like a thing you could buy in the
store yet my dad made me a pretty
crooker glove and it had metal
fingers
that like were fairly flimsy like i
don't think anybody could have gotten
hurt but he made me a glove with metal
fingers
and then we got this like there were no
freddy krueger masks yet we got this we
got a hat and then we got this putty
and he made like my face look burned
and uh that's how much cooler being a
kid was back then you could dress up as
freddy cr back then i said you could
dress up as freddy krueger
i was like 10. listen and parents
started listening to just finally lit up
when talking about the kid experience of
halloween at the buzzer you just turned
to camera and talked about your own
personal magic
you want to see me land up again
in some time you see me light up again
i went to a halloween party and sex with
a girl that had double d's and she
cooked me scramble the next morning
there's a lineup for you
i was 32 when that happened it was great
scrambled eggs apple scrambles like a
breakfast meat in pennsylvania oh i
never scrabble scrapple oh i don't know
what that is huh i don't know what that
is
scrapple it's a it's a meat
replace it with sausage just doesn't
matter social
scrapple no it's a breakfast meat that's
only in pennsylvania
oh and my eyes have to have laid eyes on
that uh it's delicious you would be
freaked out if you saw it and but if i
gave you a bite of it you would think it
was delicious okay
uh i'll tell you a story but it was in
pennsylvania and she cooked me scrapple
the next day good i mean god bless
and you and then you also looked at the
inside tag of her brazilian huh you
looked at the inside tag of her
brassiere i don't need to see tags
i know my way around
what was her costume what was yours she
was dressed up if i remember correctly
she was dressed up
like almost like a
disney type princess i think
okay like almost like a snow white or
something
i'll walk right into it guys there's a
specialist for just about everything and
we want to talk candid here yeah car
breaks down you go to a mechanic you got
a problem with the shower you call the
plumber so when you want to get your
uneven crooked teeth fixed you see an
orthodontist they're the specialists and
that's what sets candid the invisible
comfortable and removable aligners above
the rest there are poorly reviewed uh
aligners out there that are insanely
priced and these companies use general
dentist candid only works with
orthodontist candid also uses the same
orthodontist for you that created your
plan and that person's with you from
start to finish so you never have to
wonder about how you're doing your
treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist which we keep saying who's
an expert in tooth movement and you can
book an appointment at a candid studio
near you or do everything from the
comfort and convenience of your own home
plus with your liner treatment you're
going to get candids teeth whitening for
free so candy can help you get
straighter brighter smile that you've
always wanted right now you can get
started from home for just 15 with a
candid starter kit or you can book an
appointment at a candid studio near you
today go to candid c-o-dot-com
taste buds and use the code taste buds
that's candid c-o-dot-com taste buds use
the code taste buds take advantage of
this limited time offer for a 15 starter
kit and the free whitening
candidco.com taste buds
code taste buds one of your favorite
materials returns to the foreground
as our hero material offering comfort
coziness and the weightlessness to keep
you going on your feet all day long all
right i hear what i'm saying well let's
tell them what we're talking about well
we're talking about the benefits of all
birds wool
runners uh these are shoes okay
all birds encouraging listeners like you
to go and check out their original style
check out what these guys are doing we
are settling into the fall season life
is picking up again we know what's
coming for us these days staying
comfortable it's at the top of your list
okay you want to be warm but you want to
be comfortable you're going to lace up
this pair are all birds wool runners and
you're going to see that all birds has
redefined what it means to be
comfortable all day long
made from soft sustainable merino wool
the wool runners don't just feel good
they look good too i have a three pair
three yeah i have a pair that i had
before they were ever a sponsor
and i bought my dad a pair and now since
they became a sponsor i ordered another
pair yeah they're they're made uh really
uh also i think it's this should touch
on this but they are made sustainably
which we will touch on which i thought
was really cool then i threw them on and
dude they are like
one of the most comfortable pairs of
shoes i love it they're made with soft
itch-free
uh materials and they're naturally
durable they're zq certified merino wool
they're the most sustainable wall that
you can get with that that zq certain i
don't i knew very little about zq merino
wool until all birds came
and i'm learning that this is the most
sustainable of all walls they are simple
too i like that they go with anything
they're simple stylish you get like one
full color uh proving the comfort design
and sustainability don't have to be
mutually exclusive you can machine wash
them easy to wear easy to clean and
they're a great shoe to wear with almost
any outfit they look classic you know
especially with a pant like this a
jogger pant yeah this is what i was
getting at actually before all birds is
a carbon neutral company thanks to
sustainable practices like using natural
materials and perching purchasing carbon
offsets uh
yeah they know we can create a more
sustainable future together but only if
we hold ourselves accountable to tread
lighter on the planet so start off the
season right with a pair of wool runners
from all birds find your own pair of
wool runners at allbirds.allbirds.com
today okay so it's a l l b i r d s dot
com check them out
uh she was beautiful she was very
beautiful uh and she really almost like
a snow white type of thing and then i dr
and i dressed up as i think i did clark
kent turning into superman
this guy with this one that's see that i
had to take the bus down from new york
to my buddy's adult halloween party
and it was kind of like you know i'm not
getting on that the club kent is is
people do it too much uh look i've seen
it done i started doing it back in 2000
you know i don't know i feel like i was
john
john ken do you know about him we just
talked about dad from superman kent or
john kent jonathan kent's his dad
so apparently uh superman had a
baby with lois lane oh his son is like
ron cantor john kentucky no john kid
cause it's named after jonathan kent
it's named after superman's dad oh so
yeah and he's bisexual yes and in the
comic he's he's like literally he
already has a love interest yeah yeah
yeah a lot the new robin is also about
that's new that's new yeah like it never
happened before or they're just redoing
an old it just happened
yesterday tell uh tell your story then
let's go to the phones yeah be more
relatable go is ringing ron kent or john
kent all right sal you don't have one
costume you remember at all
um
i was a hope this is a funny thing one
like hobo was a thing when i was when i
was really young like i i was a ghost i
was a clown i was you know i was all
those ones that you buy out of the box
with the with the rubber band that like
with the mask that hurts no i wasn't
like you know what i mean like when
you're a little you put that smock on
that's plastic yeah in the box it's
excellent that's yeah that's chinese
vintage
yeah so i had a joke i did those all the
way till you did the superman joke
doesn't really look like superman looks
like superman's pajamas yeah i wrote a
joke for a pete holmes holly monologue
about halloween where i said that we
talked about the plastic thing and i
said it looks like he went to
spider-man's barber
he's putting the smock over you so i did
that and then as i got older a little
bit past that i did like i moved on from
that children's specific costume to
doing so i remember i remember one time
i didn't know what i was going to be and
we just and i was so upset
because i had to go to school and i
didn't have a costume and like my mom
was like i gotta figure out what i can
use around the house and then she's like
i'll make you a hobo you know you take
grandpa's hat and you wriggle up and put
on your head i'll black out a tooth
and then like i'll put on the flannel
we'll rip the flannel we'll rip your
jean and i went to school as a hobo
all right different times a lot of kids
did it back then right it was the thing
i mean
lazy costumes and that's the top well
yeah i mean that was the one year but
but like it is funny that my mom's like
i have an idea we'll make you look like
a homeless person
didn't your mom show up at your school
as dressed up as what again hold me the
clown homie the clown that's right
she was dressed as a clown
soup to nuts like the shoes the face the
wig the big alpha with the big collar
the horn uh it was but she called her
homie clown because at that time we
would love tommy the clown and homie the
clown was was on television you know
what it is i think it was important case
that she did the black face under the
cloud
so you know so i had just i was freshman
year of high school freshman year of
high school and my mom goes to pick my
sister up dressed as the clown
and then i used to take the train and
get off at the train and then my
friend's parents just pick us up the
train and drive us home like a five
minute drive but it's like a 20 25
minute walk
and i get off the train and grab me a
train station in staten island and i'm
with like four or five friends and then
there's also like the friend the three
or four friends i walked was home but
then there's the other 20 30 friends
girl schools were on the platform people
were talking it was halloween so like
everyone was commiserating and i hear my
mom go sal
she's cool they still my parents call me
sally boy sally boy i came to pick you
up today i turned she's with my sister
and she's dressed she's like i'm homie
the clown oh boy and my sister's like
home either clown don't mess around like
they're singing and i just looked at her
and it was like i felt like i was in the
opening scene of saving private ryan
i just it felt like normandy i dropped
my bag i saw people like with their
mouths the gape people were like oh my
god
and i just dropped it and i turned and i
ran
as fast as i could and i didn't stop
like forrest gump
jesus i just it was a john k i was uh
john tom hanks at the top
now if i ran home
i ran i could google how far if i can
find
if i can find a beetlejuice picture can
you find a picture of your mom in that
costume i have one i have it right here
okay please yes
okay we'll show both next week yeah i
also got in trouble for a costume third
grade i was austin powers why'd you get
in trouble for that because i was doing
the bits from the movie
that's so funny so you're in third grade
saying do i make you horny yeah and that
was the first movie i ever saw in
theaters
oh that's great man
i ran 1.2 miles oh my god and i dropped
my book bag i didn't care all the
textbooks were in it i just figured
somebody would grab it for me and i got
home before she got home in the car
because i don't think she knew where i
went they were looking for me in the
streets
when i finally got home i was sitting in
front of the stoop of my building just
crying cooper
and she's like what's the matter i'm
like how could you do this to me how old
are you guys it's the whole school on
the platform i'm freshman it's one more
high school
i don't know
it might have been tears of rage
actually yeah like
and and i i feel bad now now it's like
you know awesome but like i i was like
so mad anyway i'll tell you one ques
where are we at uh we got a 43. yeah we
got to go to the phones all right i got
a [ __ ] halloween story i've been
trying to do for 15 minutes all right
i thought that was your halloween story
no you told the hobo one then you told
the homie the clown one no that just
came out that just came off of what you
were saying about your scramble all
right go ahead no it's all right i was
gonna talk about the magic of a kid we
had we lived in these garden apartments
there were three floors each and it was
like a good 20 buildings
all the kids were were like that's who
we hung out with as growing up
the buildings in the stairwells at every
stairwell landing in the front of the
building had this octagon type window
that you could look at like a little
porthole kind of thing and uh there was
a kid a little older than us named mario
that lived on my building on the third
floor and we were walking through and a
woman
who we thought was literally mentally
unstable like a lunatic but she was just
playing a halloween role
she was looking out of her window and
looking at us and pointing to us and
going like this like point and going
like this
that's so scary right and we're like oh
my god this woman like
do you guys see that you guys see that
this woman and she'd be looking at us
again she'd go like this she point she'd
go like this right so
little did we know we run we go another
building trick-or-treating we're all
talking about it anyone see this woman
be careful stay away from this woman
the kid mario who's a little older went
in the house went up there and i guess
either he knew her or he was old enough
to go see to check it out or what what
have you and when he got up there i
guess the woman was like i'm just trying
to scare the kids right
he agreed to do this she goes in the
house takes ketchup she puts it all over
his neck all over his neck then she goes
to the porthole she grabs him by his
hair and she he stands up in the window
and she's holding our friend's head
dripping with ketchup and shaking his
head and he's going and she's going like
it's pointless and we went oh [ __ ] she
beheaded mario that is amazing and we
ran and and and
and and it was like an hour which felt
like a lifetime of us like trying to
like get our parents save him like
wondering is it real is it not real but
but we we really didn't know
and my point is is that that [ __ ] don't
happen as well no you can't do that
anymore you can't roll no i'm saying
yeah all right that's a great
made some valid arguments that's a great
story all right let's look at a couple
comments and then see who the winner is
here
adults that get more excited for
halloween than kids do have some
childhood trauma they refuse to work out
halloween as an adult is enjoying
it vicariously i like giving out candy
and checking out the cookies okay so
there's someone who took it as halloween
from my bell getting rang point of view
right not even taking their kids right
yeah as an adult i get to keep my candy
good point definitely halloween as a kid
it just feels depressing now realizing
that i'm old
jesus god guys
you want to take a couple
halloween as an adult is sad either
you're giving yourself diabetes or liver
damage and you're you are into dressing
up
hopefully both halloween as an adult is
only fun if you have or prefer to be
around piles of obnoxious children
puking up candy is much more fun than
puking up spiced alcohol halloween is an
adult boring as hell if you don't have
any friends
jesus christ
just a message to the fans what sad
lives
what are you guys doing here you go
adults all the way i can do whatever i
want drink party or sacrifice a cat yeah
it cost me some money but who cares
derosa defending alcohol again that
might be the winner because it's so
spot-on
yeah let's keep let's get a little more
in there this is a big one i want people
i really want to hear different
i celebrate halloween decor year-round
so i'd have to go with an adult on this
one also as a kid halloween was the
devil in my family
i told you
celebrating halloween as an adult has
two options be stuck inside all night
handing out candy or wake up with the
worst stomach ache and hangover kids oh
my god
i mean those negative nellies left and
right here
i don't dress up as
i enjoy going to a halloween party as an
adult more than walking blocks on end
while my parents are getting divorced
all right that's the that's the winner
right there follow
at money's vault i'm sorry follow at
money's underscore vault
uh thanks pimp let's go do a refresh and
a and a vote
uh humble pie segment drum roll it
pimperoo
10 000 votes not very many today
[Applause]
it was nearly 70 30 or more in favor of
what did we do last week
the candies
peanut butter cups this week i dude i
did not again think i thought it was
anybody's ballgame i don't tell you
another reason this few adults go out on
halloween
party i'll tell you another reason i
thought you had a real real fighting
chance because and you didn't bring this
up halloween as an adult is is is is in
insanely longer you're an adult most of
your life so you you have the halloween
experience for 60 years as opposed to
10. you know what i mean but anyway this
is a
78.2 percent to
21.8 percent in favor of halloween this
did
and is that the biggest margin of
victory we've ever had or did we ever
get in the chat the boy band was worse
this oh i just you're losing your mind
that you wanted to tout before we want
to sign off yeah
this is the most miserable audience of
people not even one of them said i love
seeing the joy on my child's face
they were just
but i can't i'm joking guys we love you
you're miserable oh we love you yeah and
you're miserable too and i'm visible
that i lost you um
yeah
you're dropping my dates in up top right
of all of them okay i still love you
babe still love you too
boy
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste bud